hemos hablado bastante sobre la idea de
que si tenemos una economía de mercado
capitalista entonces tendremos en el
mejor de los casos crecimiento económico
pero por definición en la economía de
mercado tendremos a personas que les va
muy bien y a otras personas que no les
va tan bien por lo que también tendremos
desigualdad la desigualdad es una
consecuencia de la economía de mercado y
no es algo que necesariamente querramos
eliminar ya que esto podría dañar el
crecimiento económico y el crecimiento
económico es algo que podría beneficiar
a todos a nivel per cápita incluso a
aquellas personas que no están en el
decir o per sentir o cuartil superior no
siempre pero se podría dar esa situación
teniendo esto en mente pensemos un poco
más acerca de la desigualdad cómo se
mide y cómo está ligada a cosas como el
capital o el crecimiento del ingreso del
capital o rendimiento del capital esta
gráfica es del libro de thomas piketty
publicado en su página web todas las
gráficas que use en su libro y trata
sobre la desigualdad en el ingreso en
eeuu de 1910 a 2010 el mide esto con la
participación de el decil o 10% superior
en el ingreso nacional este punto de
aquí nos dice que en 1910 el 10%
superior de las personas que reciben
ingresos reciben un poco más del 40% del
ingreso nacional cuando llegamos al
final de la década de 1920 recibían casi
el 50 por ciento del ingreso nacional el
10% superior o decidir superior de las
personas que reciben ingresos recibían
casi a la mitad del ingreso nacional
conforme pasamos por la gran depresión
en especial después de la segunda guerra
mundial esto cae a casi el 30 por ciento
y durante las décadas de 1970 y 1980
hasta la fecha ha vuelto a subir al
rango del 40 por ciento por lo que el
decir superior de los que reciben
ingresos están recibiendo casi la mitad
de la luz de sol nacional
vamos a visualizar cómo es que esto está
sucediendo
numéricamente imaginemos que ésta es su
economía en el año 1 vamos a copiarlo ok
y digamos que esta es la fracción que
pongo en naranja de lo que recibe el
decir superior aproximadamente un tercio
en el año 1 la forma en la que esto
puede aumentar del 33.3 por ciento que
la gráfica estaría más o menos por aquí
no sé quizá en la década de 1960
de manera que el esi superior tenga una
participación cada vez mayor del ingreso
nacional es que esta sección naranja
aumentará o creciera más rápidamente que
la sección verde por ejemplo si esto
creciera un 10% mientras que esto otro
creciera un 5% pues la sección naranja
aumentaría más que la sección verde con
el paso del tiempo como hemos visto en
vídeos anteriores aun cuando esto ocurra
lo que por definición aumenta la
desigualdad puede darse el escenario en
el que el otro 90% aún tenga un pastel
más grande por lo que a nivel
capital les pueda ir mejor pero el
objetivo de este vídeo no es ese el
objetivo de este vídeo es llegar esta
idea con la idea del aumento en el
rendimiento del capital que está
generando este fenómeno y generando
desigualdad como hemos visto con
anterioridad riqueza e ingreso no son lo
mismo pero la riqueza puede ser una
representación mientras más riquezas
tengas recibirás más ingresos por dichas
riquezas por lo que otra forma de
dividir la economía es que en lugar de
pensar en el decir superior y el otro
90% de los que reciben ingresos pues
podríamos pensar en que tanto de ese
ingreso va para los dueños del capital y
cuánto de esto va para las personas que
proporcionan la mano de obra esta
porción de aquí es lo que va para los
dueños del capital así que esto va al
capital a las personas dueñas de los
terrenos de los edificios y de los
recursos
y esta otra porción es lo que va para
los que realizan la mano de obra
aplicando la misma idea si la sección
azul aumenta más rápidamente y
continuamente que el pastel verde
entonces el porcentaje del ingreso que
va para el capital va a aumentar cada
vez más y debido a que las economías del
mercado el capital no está repartido
equitativamente debido a que a su vez el
ingreso no está repartido
equitativamente al tener más crecimiento
en el rendimiento del capital tendremos
este fenómeno de aquí arriba aquí quiero
aclarar que este crecimiento de aquí a
abajo si ustedes escuchen el término
rendimiento de capital en conjunción con
el libro de piquet y que compara el
rendimiento de capital con la tasa de
crecimiento este crecimiento de aquí no
es el rendimiento de capital para
conocer el rendimiento de capital
tenemos que conocer el ingreso que
genera el capital y también el valor de
este capital bien a este diagrama solo
conozco el ingreso generado por el
capital pero no conozco el valor del
mismo por lo que no voy a poder conocer
el rendimiento del capital
este crecimiento que muestra aquí en el
que quizá después de algunos años esta
sección azul aumenta hasta aquí mientras
que el pastel verde crece hasta acá
este crecimiento de aquí podemos verlo
como el aumento en el ingreso del
capital lo cual es algo que no
escuchamos mucho pero este crecimiento
de aquí que quizá no se es de más 5 por
ciento de la economía total es la cee a
la que nos hemos estado refiriendo el
crecimiento de toda la economía